that's a great question you know when
you look at the research what it
suggests is that that there are some
differences in in terms of age segments
there are differences in how people use
technology there are certain differences
in terms of what people want but when
you get a little bit lower than that
when you get down to needs the needs are
very similar and then when you get down
to values what you find is that the
generations are really closely connected
in our country this is a powerful force
and so grandparents really care about
their grandchildren they care about
their children and vice versa the
grandchildren today young people today
care about their parents and their
grandparents so you have this real
cohesiveness this connectedness and so
from our standpoint we try to think that
way we try to think intergenerationally
so it's just to give you an example
right now we're working very hard at
AARP to try to get the State Children's
Health Insurance Program reauthorized
and expanded and why do we want to do
that we want to do that because those
are our grandchildren and because
children are the future of the country
so that interconnectedness is very
strong and very important
well it's changing quite rapidly and the
reason for this is that as the boomers
age and as people in their 60s and 70s
age they tend to be healthier and better
educated than previous generations and
so you have people living longer and you
have this huge cohort of boomers 78
million baby boomers coming into their
older years so what all this adds up to
is that our society is aging and as far
as how old is old nobody really knows
you know there's a line that that says
basically old is 10 years older than I
am the pressing issue for us today is to
try to get health care fixed because
what's happening is more and more people
are unable to afford health care
insurance even if their employer offers
it to more and more people are changing
or losing jobs and when they do that
they can't take their insurance with
them they're worried about their
children they're they're worried about
so many aspects of health care so many
bankruptcies in this country are due to
health costs and right now about
two-thirds of all adults in this country
think that the coming generation is
going to be worse off than their parents
and if that happened it would be the
first time in American history and a
major reason for that is health care and
also financial security not being able
to save enough for retirement pensions
going south trying to care for aging
parents and having kids at home and not
being able really to draw to save at
work so these are the issues that are
top of the agenda for us
I think the young have a responsibility
to the old and very definitely older
people have a responsibility to the
young there's no question every
generation has to be responsible to the
other that's what that's what society is
built upon and you know there was a
congressman who came to the AARP board
one day and he said you know that young
people have to pay for older people to
receive Social Security and I'm going to
go out and talk to young people and I'm
going to make them madder than hell
about this and of course there is no
intergenerational warfare in this
country he was he was dead wrong they're
young people are interested in their
parents and their grandparents and as I
said before vice versa we have to all
care about each other and if we do that
we'll be a better society well I think
there's a formula and the formula is not
a deep secret the way to age well I
think is to stay mentally and physically
active and then the obvious things you
know eat well don't smoke those kinds of
things get plenty of exercise but mental
and physical activity are the most
important things that people can do to
age well
it's a tough question people do not like
that idea now you know if you're 41 or
under right now you're gonna have to
work to your 67 but at the same time
many people want to work into their
older years there's another way to think
about it which has been called longevity
indexing and some countries do this and
what they basically say is okay let's
actually figure out how long you're
expected to live and we'll give you your
Social Security money stretched out over
that period of time so you get less
money per year over a longer period of
years that's one way to think about it
there are a lot of ways to consider
fixing the system